[Music]
on the dish this morning Angie Marr Noah
doesn't like Mar at lechwa chaveau or
the three horses it is the finest of
fine dining in New York City with dress
codes impeccable service and the world's
most Exquisite ingredients Mark comes
from a Chinese family but French food
has been her focus and it's brought her
worldwide Acclaim when she was
unceremoniously detached from her last
restaurant Marsh started rather
dramatically all over again
[Music]
originally from Seattle Angie Mark was
taken on childhood trips to New York
City in Paris which made her realize
what she wanted to make some of the best
food in the world
my father grew up in a lot of poverty he
put himself through dental school and
really like tried to provide for us and
when I called him and I said look like I
I don't want to be in the corporate
world I want to cook he said okay you're
never going to see your family
you're never going to have a holiday off
it's a lot of work
but I understand why you love it so you
should do it
Mar honed her craft at kitchens in New
York before taking over the famed
Beatrice Inn as executive chef in 2013.
but in the middle of the pandemic her
old landlord decided to raise her rent
40 percent
somar shuddered the Beatrice and opened
a new restaurant right next door when
you open this place I just want to I
want to make sure I get this quote right
but um
about leaving Beatrice you said about
the landlord opening next door was my
big view to them it was
yeah
it was kind of a statement wasn't it
[Music]
Mar the rare celebrity chef who doesn't
leave the kitchen
is now the Relentless force behind
lechwa shovo it's gonna be two tasting
money
what time do you arrive at work every
day 8 AM and when do you leave
maybe two a.m
if I'm not here
we don't open
at lichwa chaveau jeans t-shirts hoodies
and sneakers are all strictly prohibited
which is increasingly rare in New York
City
and the dress code isn't the only thing
that cuts directly against today's
Trends I'm not big on local I'm not big
on you know buying every like you'll
never catch me at the farmers market but
it's so unseasonal to say that I know
like it's nobody says that I know I
might be the only one
I don't care where it comes from in the
world I don't care if it's in season or
not I just want the best
Le choir chefo features either a four
course prefix menu or a 10 course Diga
Station menu which includes a parade of
desserts
for us Mar opted for the latter
starting us off with an amuse Bouche an
aerated leek in potato vichyswa followed
by a croissant stuffed with black and
white truffles porcini mushrooms
pistachio and golden osetra caviar no is
that not the best bread and butter
you've ever had yes
oh my gosh the next dish represented a
blend of Mars background and her
Washington State roots
this is a cannelloni if we do now it's
actually not pasta this is a Crystal
dumpling technique so like you know when
you go to dim sum and like they have the
like hakao which is completely
see-through
that's essentially what this is
we incorporate Nori and squash blossoms
into the actual
rapper of the cannelloni and then you
have three different shellfish
and it's all finished with a saffron
cream
it's like the Pacific Northwest you can
taste the pine you can taste the cold
water yeah right yeah there was cervel
Devoe with foie gras Madera sauce and
burgundy truffles I never put anything
on the plate that shouldn't be eaten I
love that
gorgeous
a truffled soup with chestnuts legumes
and vermouth encased in a crusted pastry
made of croissant dough what do I do
you're going to cut the pastry off of
the top it should just pop right off oh
come on
it just it screams elegance and
holidays and yeah
give it to me
balatine of hen was stuffed with lobster
served with cognac sauce
she closed out the meal with a light
salad and cheese before moving on to a
selection of desserts the crate
Mademoiselle prepared tableside was the
highlight oh my goodness literally oh
yes
along with oolong tea ice cream a
chanterelle mushroom creme and finally
Palm duffine it's like dipping your
French fries in a vanilla milkshake it
is
I don't think I've ever done a dish
where I eat every single bite of every
single dish and I'm doing that then
we've done our job properly right
you were in heaven yeah we've done a lot
of restaurants and we've had a lot of
food here that may be the best food I've
ever had that's great really it was it
was I mean she's amazing and the fact
that she's there so much and she's not
just trying to franchise doing all these
different restaurants focusing on making
great great things in this one place and
the best quality no matter where it's
from no matter where it's from she says
yeah yeah I just love that it's nicely
it's a nice tight restaurant it's it's
manageable it's not a big place no yeah
yeah love reopening bring your drawer by
the way yeah I can't wait let's go let's
go